Here's what we will cover.
first an overview of computer science
You want to make clear?
What this discipline is about and so
you can better appreciate the role of discrete mathematics in
computer science.
Now this quick mathematics.
and I want to
take you back to
Comments, I've made before about discrete mathematics. It is a it
is one of the branches of mathematics that requires
no prerequisites.
And what do I mean by prerequisite say what Calculus if
you want to be able to understand differentiation
and integration the prerequisite
for single variable calculators
algebra?
so
you cannot just
jump to calculus without having some
exposure to
At least Elementary algebra or for example if
you want to study.
Probability theory if your data sizes. This is
something
you know the center of white.
mmm
Well, you'll have to learn.
probably theory has a lot of prerequisites something that
is not even pointed out in many of
the textbooks.
probability theory has prerequisites in
single variable calculus linear algebra
abstract algebra and discrete mathematics
now the script mathematics by itself has no
prerequis. So what I mean is this if you're someone
who has
taken
a high school mathematics
and you don't even remember classical algebra,
you know things like
finding the square root.
You know.
Algebraic properties like associativity commutativity that
kind of stuff right?
The quadratic equation functions. If you don't even
remember those and even if you haven't taken those you can still start
with discrete mathematics. Why am I even making this point?
because discrete mathematics covers
the most fundamental mathematical
Concepts
Concepts that you will encounter in all of mathematics
You see one of the problems with learning.
One of the obstacles to learning mathematics is the
Symbols this is something I always say there are two obstacles that
you will encounter when you want to
learn anything in mathematics. One of them is the symbols.
the meaning of those symbols and the terminology
discrete mathematics will studying discrete mathematics will
expose you to both these symbols
to which I'm referring and the terminology.
So if you want to become very proficient in any mathematical
branch.
Whether you want to be a computer scientist or data scientists
discrete mathematics is the place to start.
And should you be should you learn discrete mathematics
you can then?
continue
developing your mathematical knowledge and enter the realm
of pure at Applied Mathematics.
I will talk about we will talk about pure mathematics
as well.
Then we will jump into the different.
subjects that
are within
The topic of discrete mathematics including logic and
propositional calculus and how they relate to
computer algorithms computer programming algorithms.
Data structures of which there are two categories and
linear and nonlinear.
If you have heard of binary trees.
and
search algorithms on binary trees
and if you want to know how those work.
And even how more advanced data structures and algorithms
work?
then
graph theory is something you definitely want to look into.
You cannot be a computer scientist. If you know don't know graph
Theory.
And then we will.
How do two things after that introduction?
to these Concepts
We will look at the applications the direct applications
of these topics and discrete mathematics followed by
tutorial what I will take you to vs code,
which is just some code editor.
And I will show you.
some mathematical syntax
and
in parallel the python
version of it
so I will show you a programming implementation, which
I
know most of you are probably familiar with even if
you don't or python you'll be able to make sets of
the code
so I'll show you the code version and the mathematical version
of the same concept.